- If it's the weekend,
especially a pay weekend,
you know, you can kinda
cut up a little bit,
and then you go up in there on Monday,
and it's like, what
the hell just happened?
(swoop)
(squeak)
- I think I waste a lot of
money on luxury grocery items.
I don't need to spend seven
dollars on a tiny hunk of cheese.
- About four hundred
dollars eating out a month.
Because I hate to cook.
- I'm gonna go out on
a limb here and guess
that my spending vice is
alcohol and going out.
I'm gonna estimate, like, one
to two hundred per weekend.
I guess in a month, that would be like
eight hundred to a thousand per month.
That's like with, for...oh my god, the
producer's face is terrified right now.
This is a ballpark estimate.
- And I am sure that I
spend too much on Amazon.
I'll be like, oh my god, it would be
so great if I had a yoga mat at home,
and then I'll buy a yoga
mat, and then I don't use it.
- So I don't think I'm
going to be surprised,
but it's probably gonna hit me
in the gut, like a gut check.
(sigh)
Oh my gosh.
Seamless.
Domo taco.
14.24, and I probably could multiply
that by a thousand times, because
that's how much Domo Taco I eat.
Another Domo Taco.
Domo Taco.
Domo Taco purchase.
(sped up voice)
It doesn't even have what I ate,
but clearly it must've been
tasty as hell to be 28.72.
(drumroll)
(buzzer)
It makes me feel like everything
that my dad tells me as far as, son,
you need to budget, you need to
think about what you're buying,
you don't need to spend 20
dollars when you go eat out,
it is ringing in my head right now,
and it's making me say, Trey,
you have got to get your shit together.
- One discovery so far, I go to the
grocery store twice a day on average.
I spent 21 dollars and 77
cents at the grocery store.
I spent 14 dollars and 25
cents at that grocery store.
Nine dollars and 28
cents at a grocery story.
(voice sped up)
(drumroll)
(boing)
Oh, shit.
Oooh, that hurts.
- Okay, Amazon, 22 bucks,
so 100 dollars at CB2,
another 22 dollars on Amazon,
(voice sped up)
(drumroll)
(boing)
(sigh)
Did I really need to buy
sheets from West Elm?
I wish I could return
them, but I've already
slept in them and they feel great.
- All right, so first we
have on the latest statement,
um, Macri Park for 15 dollars.
Yep, that's a bar, so that checks out.
23.60, that is a restaurant in Brooklyn
where I go to get margaritas.
So, yep, that checks out as well.
(voice sped up)
(drumroll)
(dings)
Oh my god, just in one month?
I've had so many dumb expenses, oh my god.
I should just convince
drunk me to take the subway
instead of hopping into a cab,
and that would save me so much money.
(swoop)
It is very easy and quick to spend money,
and it's nothing but a tap,
a tap of that Domo Taco,
the food's there in 30 minutes.
But five taps of that Domo
Taco and you have got,
you know, you're out of maybe 100 dollars.
- I feel like I thought
that I was saving money,
because I haven't bought anything big,
and everything I've been buying is in
like 12 to 15 dollar increments,
but now that I'm looking at
it, those have really added up.
- In general, I mean,
I'm just trying to be
tighter about my money, always,
and try to think through smarter ways
to track my spending, and how I
enable myself to spend on stuff.
I think this is very
illuminating for that.
- If you are privileged
enough and lucky enough
to be able to treat yourself and
take care of yourself and pay attention
to the things that make you
happy, then I say, go for it.
(upbeat bouncy pop)